all right folks today we're discussing
five reasons that cnn
is fake news this particular video is
sponsored by
raycon so let me just preface all of
this by saying there are some good
reporters over at cnn not everything
that is
on cnn is fake news but cnn promoting
itself
as an apple is an apple a banana is a
banana an apple is not a banana the most
trusted name in news free of bias
free of all sorts of subjectivity
problems
all that's nonsense that's the part
that's nonsense what we mean is that
when they proclaim they are an objective
new source that obviously is not true
there are five specific areas in which
we can clearly say
that cnn is fake news number one
selection bias
there are a couple of different kinds of
bias when you do a story there's the
bias that exists within
a story for example right there's bias
where you just kind of slide the opinion
right into the story we'll get to that
in just a little bit but there's a
broader problem of bias and that is the
selection bias what kind of news do you
choose to cover so we here at daily
wedding we're biased we're conservative
we choose to cover certain types of news
because we find it more interesting
cnn however says they are objective in
their news coverage and then you have
the head of cnn announcing
just this last week that he was actually
going to hire a new race team
not like indy 500 race team like an
actual team just to cover racial issues
because it is very
obvious to jeff zucker that the biggest
issue in america right now
is racial unrest which of course cnn has
been driving i mean cnn has been
promoting the idea that america is a
deeply evil country
america is a deeply racist country
america is systemically
bigoted do you think there will be a lot
of ideological diversity inside
that particular level of coverage i
think not selection bias is when you
spend two years promoting trump russia
conspiracy theories without any real
hard evidence
proclaiming the evidence is just around
the corner and here's just a brief
montage
of some of the trump russia over-the-top
stuff bombshell bombshell bombshell
bombshell
the biggest bombshell buzzfeed's latest
bombshell bombshell
may be the most damning allegation yet
if true if true
if true if true important caveat if true
could mean the president obstructed
justice
the president's got to lose his job the
trump presidency would be over that's
fueling new talk of
impeachment historically it's a b-line
to impeachment but yeah so
this president committing a federal
crime
latest on the robert mueller russia
investigation mueller investigation the
russian investigation trump's russia
ties and robert mueller the real russia
story russia probe the ongoing russia
approach russia probe the russian
investigation but mueller and the russia
pro russia
synergies they wonder if russia has
compromising information on the
president
what is the source for the president's
claim that they have found no collusion
with russia he misspelled collusion
every day we're trying to keep track
of the drip drip drip of the russia
investigation drip drip drip drip drip
drip drip drip drip
trip to trump and russia to see whether
trump
was secretly working for russia to bring
it back to russia and russia
russia russia russia russia russia
russia and russia russia russia russia
breaking news breaking news it was
always breaking news
and it turned out the news never broke
it turns out the whole narrative was
just not true that's what cnn does
and then they find another narrative
that narrative doesn't work and then
sometimes they'll actually just falsify
that narrative like for example
covington catholic let's assume
for a second that that had been a true
story that cnn had covered a
kid who was making fun with a smile of a
native american he was making
wearing a maga hat why is that a
national news story isn't that a local
news story does that rise to the level
of everyone in america needs to know
about this
well of course not but it's a selection
bias issue why
exactly does cnn decide that they have
to cover for example
the black lives matter movement and the
protests without covering
the number of people who are being shot
in nearly the same way in new york and
chicago the vast wave in crime that is
now engulfing
cities around the united states well
because of course it's a selection by
its issue one narrative matters and one
doesn't
number two claims of objectivity so
remember cnn keeps claiming
that pretty much all of its hosts are
objective news anchors and this of
course is absolute sheer nonsense and
the anchors themselves know this
and if they don't then they're just
being foolish so don lemon will claim
that he is objective
in fact just in the last couple of weeks
he went on another tv show
and he said well you know what i am an
objective journalist and when i speak
about race it's my truth take a listen
to this
my role as a journalist is to speak from
my truth and from my lens and from where
i come from
and i don't think those things are
biases i am a black man
who grew up and who lives and survives
and works in america i have a certain
perspective and a certain point of view
and i'm bringing that important part of
the diverse
um culture of this company to the fore
and i should be
and so the people who don't want to hear
that they who don't want to hear my
truth
will say to you that i am biased i'm not
biased
this is my truth as a black man in
america
those are contradictory once you say it
is your truth it is not the truth it is
not an objective claim
it is a subjective claim about your
personal anecdotal experiences
that's not objectivity that is
subjectivity or when cnn has chris cuomo
interview his brother
and they do their buddy comedy routine
from step brothers with john c
reilly and will ferrell right and chris
cuomo just does this right they're going
to demonstrate to each other how much
did mom love you best
absolutely objective jim acosta jim
acosta all over everything
okay and ladies find you a man who loves
you like jim acosta loves jim acosta
is there any question that jim acosta is
a motivated player in this
jim acosta celebrates his attempts to
kind of goad president trump so he can
get a headline
mr president will you stop calling us
the enemy of the people sir
will you stop calling the press the
enemy of the people sir
mr president will you stop calling the
press the enemy of the people sir
[Music]
is that objectivity i think not number
three the chirons
so the chiron writer at cnn is basically
just an editorialist it's pretty
incredible actually so if you have
noticed cnn chirons have become more and
more opinionated so for example just in
the last few weeks
there was a report on mount rushmore and
the chiron writer decided
that they were going to write in the
chiron that president trump was
celebrating quote-unquote independence
day they put independence in scare
quotes now the actual official name
of the holiday independence day is
independence day you don't have to scare
quote it the reason for scare quoting it
was the idea that america was not
actually celebrating its independence on
july 4th
america was celebrating its brutality
and vicious evil
but the reporter here is also egregious
she says that mount rushmore is stolen
native american land
with two slave holders on it listen to
this clip from cnn the most trusted name
in news
as americans face a reckoning over
racism past
and present there's no message of
healing from the white house
instead president trump is calling a
black lives matter street mural a symbol
of hate
and jay kicking off the independence day
weekend president trump will be
at mount rushmore where he'll be
standing in front of a monument
of two slave owners and on land wrestled
away
from native americans told that uh be
focusing on the effort to quote
tear down our country's history the cnn
chiron writers they do this sort of
stuff
all the time i remember maybe a few
months back
there was this vast pro-gun virginia
rally and cnn decided to feature a
chiron about a mass shooting at the same
time
as the pro-gun virginia rally had
nothing to do with the story they just
left it up
on the screen or for example cnn's
tendency to use fact-checking kyron's
with president trump
so what they'll do is they'll say trump
claims x and then
in parentheses he didn't right they they
don't do any of that stuff for democrats
they never do that with joe biden they
only ever do this
with president trump that is a
particular kind of bias that is not news
that is editorializing if you want to
come on afterward and then
fact check what the president said and
do that in even-handed fashion that is
one way to do it but very often
the chirons actually are not even real
fact checks very often they are
fact-checking implications which is
something
that so-called objective news sources
like to do so trump will say something
100 true like he'll say
we're doing more raw tests than anybody
in america and then they'll say
wrong on a per capita level we are not
it's like he didn't say per capita he
said we're doing more tests in america
than anywhere else
which is true and the chiron writers are
they're just liars very often
[Music]
now i know you're enjoying this video
which means you're probably listening on
wireless earbuds and if you're listening
on the wrong way unless you're about
you're doing it wrong which is why
you need raycon raycon is great they've
got these wireless earbuds that come
without the stems they come without the
wires they fit your ear perfectly which
is one of the great things they're not
one size
fits all right it comes with a card the
card has a variety of fits you can stick
it in your ear
and it fits perfectly and blocks out the
sound of your children screaming at you
i know i've tried it myself it comes in
a variety
of colors and patterns they are super
comfortable and again they come with a
variety of fit options i find super
convenient the compact carrying case can
charge earbuds four times
on a single charge unlike some of your
other wireless options raycon earbuds
again stylish discreet no dangling wires
no stems they are great for video chats
they are great for listening to videos
like this one raycon earbuds also
started about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market they sound just as amazing as the
other top audio brands you know
raycons are great from working from home
working out listening to music and
podcasts for hours without
driving anyone else crazy or them
driving you crazy their everyday e25
earbuds those are the best model yet six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass
more compact design that gives you that
nice noise isolating fit click the link
in the description below get 15 off your
order right now again click that link in
the description below get 15
off your order of raycons number four
creation of narratives
so there's a good movie with jake
gyllenhaal called nightcrawler
in that movie jake gyllenhaal originally
plays sort of this stringer who goes
around
taking photographs of car crashes he
brings them to the local news channel
and then the news channel airs them in
the cell he makes his money he realizes
at a certain point that he can
actually craft the narrative he can be
the narrative and so he starts
to actually involve himself in crimes so
he can be the first person on the scene
in order to craft the narrative and then
he becomes like this big time reporter
because of all of this now cnn kind of
does this
okay cnn crafts narratives by basically
deciding what to cover how to cover
those things the most obvious narrative
that cnn has crafted in the past few
months
is the idea that governor andrew cuomo
of new york was good at his job so they
had chris cuomo interview him
every day and andrew cuomo got to go on
and just do propaganda hour with his
brother
i hope you are able to appreciate what
you did in your state
and what it means for the rest of the
country now and what it will always mean
to those who love and care about you the
most
i'm wowed by what you did and more
importantly i'm wowed by how you did it
this was very hard i know it's not over
but obviously i love you as a brother
obviously i'll never be objective
obviously i think you're the best
politician in the country
um but i hope you feel good about what
you did for your people because i know
they appreciate
it nothing's perfect you'll have your
critics thank you but i've never seen
anything like what you did
and that's why i'm so happy to have had
you on the show
they kept saying over and over that
andrew cuomo chose press conference is
live look at how what a strong
leader he is at this point 33 000 people
have died in new york
a multiple of any other state in the
union like a vast multiple over states
like florida which of course ron
desantis is a bad guy but there's a
narrative that has to be promulgated at
cnn
and that narrative is democrats good
republicans bad therefore desantis bad
cuomo good and it's absolute nonsense or
how about the creation of the narrative
that black lives matter is only about
police brutality
that black lives matter it really
doesn't apply to all black lives matter
this is something don lemon said openly
the black lives matter movement was
started because it was talking about
police brutality
if you want an all-black lives matter
movement that talks about
gun violence in communities including
you know black communities then start
that movement with that name
why shouldn't we be concerned about
black lives lost
through a wide variety of other means
and in numbers far greater than those
lost in police brutality
but more than that it's obviously also
not true right the fact is that blm as
an organization is extraordinarily
radical they're a neo-marxist
organization they make this absolutely
clear on their website but this is not
up for debate
over on cnn so cnn has a narrative to
push the narrative is
america's racist and the police are bad
and they will ignore any other issues
that complicate that narrative
including the issue that the black lives
matter organization is not just about
police brutality
and also that the greatest threats to
black life in the united states do not
come from the cops and in fact lack of
cops
provides probably a greater not probably
certainly a greater threat to black life
than presence of cops in black
communities okay other narratives how
about the brett kavanaugh was probably a
rapist narrative
right christine blasey ford hero brett
kavanaugh evil white villain
okay where was the evidence
turns out the evidence completely fell
apart number five ignoring facts
completely
covington catholic they'll just run with
that story and then when it turns out
that the story is not true when it turns
out that these kids were actually being
harassed by black
hebrew israelites when you get old
enough they're gonna steal your organs
it turns out that they'll just twist the
narrative into but what if it had been
true
what if it had been true or how about
ignoring the rioting and the looting
that happened throughout the united
states
during the george floyd protest saying
they were quote unquote mostly peaceful
it has been entirely peaceful
and mostly peaceful is a qualifier that
is only used for protests that cnn
particularly likes
really just an ugly a dangerous scene at
the state capitol in michigan
those pictures and those clashes really
show
um the the chaos and you're out there
with with um
with guns these quote unquote protests i
don't even think that that's the right
word
uh because protests are supposed to be
peaceful imagine if the anti-lockdown
protests had broken into mass violence
in which full streets were basically
burned to the ground and every store was
tagged
and windows had to be boarded up do you
think that would have been mostly
peaceful anti-lockdown protests
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite so the facts just
get completely ignored what are the
facts about
christine blasey ford right the fact
that her allegations turned out to be
not only evidence-less but that every
piece of evidence she cited ended up
falling apart
right she said that there were people
there who said that they were not there
she couldn't remember where this
happened or when this happened
and yet she was the heroine of the hour
here's the bottom line
cnn is just like every other quote
unquote journalistic outlet they've got
their biases the problem with cnn is
that cnn lies overtly about their own
biases
cnn will say they are the most trusted
name in news they simply
are not they are not in the news
business they are in the same business i
am in the opinion journalism business
the difference is
i'm honest enough to admit it whereas
they'll lie to you so there you have it
five reasons why cnn
is fake news if you liked this video and
you want to see more like it leave a
comment below